it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games and new releases
and this week we tee off with Rory
McIlroy's PGA Tour hit the greens with
some new features such as the new
backswing meter and aiming arc to help
you launch more accurate shots unlike
other EA sports titles Rory McIlroy's
PGA Tour uses the Frostbite 3 engine
which now allows entire courses to be
rendered at once meaning 0 low times
between holes go for that hole in one
July fourteenth let's travel back in
time five years ago and replay god of
war 3 only this time experience it in a
new light this classic title gets
remastered for the PlayStation for
bringing this critically acclaimed
single-player game to a full 1080p at 60
frames per second relive the memories as
you take on the role of fearless Kratos
as he climbs mount olympus to seek his
bloody revenge destroy the gods july 14
this is it your ultimate gaming dream
will finally come true with trials
fusion awesome level max you can finally
play as a cat riding a fire-breathing
unicorn and if that wasn't enough the
second part of the DLC contains 22 new
levels half of them being fan-made ride
that rainbow July fourteenth ps4 owners
who have not gone a chance to play the
vanishing of Ethan Carter you can now
play the vanishing of Ethan Carter on
the ps4 in this open world environment
you play as a detective and use your
paranormal abilities to help you unravel
the mystery of red creek valley unravel
the clues July fifteenth for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
always subject to change see you next
week
you